Nos dicen: "Restar", y quieren que restemos
9 de 17, o dicho de otra manera, quieren
que averigüemos a qué es equivalente 17 - 9; y nos
dan una pista, dice: "Usa la recta numérica para
resolver 17 - 9". Así que, ¿qué pasa por aquí? En
esta recta numérica podemos ver al 17 justo aquí,
y parece que dieron 9 pasos a la izquierda, lo
cual tiene sentido porque estamos restando 9,
estamos quitando 9. Así que pausa este video
y usa esta pista para pensar el resultado de
17 - 9. Muy bien, si empezamos en 17, como lo
hicimos justo aquí, y retrocedemos 9 pasos,
¿en dónde terminaremos? Bueno, veamos: un
paso, dos pasos, tres pasos, cuatro pasos,
cinco pasos, seis pasos, siete pasos, ocho
pasos y nueve pasos. Parece que llegamos a,
bueno, retrocedimos 7 pasos para llegar a 10
y parece que retrocedimos otros 2 pasos más,
así que este de acá es 9 y este
de aquí es 8, por lo tanto,
parece que 17 - 9 = 8. Otra forma de escribir
lo mismo es que: 8 = 17 - 9. Y hemos acabado.